he's he's just I just want a vector here
to work on the H
okay can see that hand already on the
inside so you don't want to go here and
then cut
here
underneath
inward
don't flap your elbow either go do the
same thing just do your thing don't go
like
this and
work so the next
step is again when you're he's trying to
strike or whatever go ahead I'm gonna
try to touch you see I'm I'm always
gonna try to make contact okay but not
contact go ahead I'm not going to make
contact where everything's unanchored
you see so we're going to make I would
always make contact you could do any
western style striking
too I'll do it on you okay so there he
do make contact and it ends up hitting
him you see that so he's going to go and
I make contact you see right right I
reach for contact you get it so he'll do
whatever he wants to punch again you see
I'm making contact the whole time so I
want to stick to him just like with my
weapons okay you don't block these
things you make connection you hold the
I adhesion okay so as he goes up what
allows for that is there's Yin space
that's Yin energy Yin energy which means
I F the yin energy to make contact do
you
see I'm not going to wait here go and
block
it so the fights already started and I
stick to him then I heal to
him that's going to be our exercise
right now if you need to don't think of
it as
yokan just go fill the in space follow
and then the parrying
over boom
bo again as you
go no keep your katatori elbow
Bend
pop same
connection same in his
body don't just attack his
arm
War connection
po okay let's put that together it's
very tempting as as he goes and you go
and like just move it out of the way but
look at his
posture that is a kind of Terry but I I
already have connection and so I want to
be in his body on that movement do you
understand so I had connection this this
move moves
him okay not just gets out of the
way this this thing moves him
okay so we go following it's going to
pass pass that body into this arm over
here got it and this arm's not going to
push that way this arm's taking it this
way that's the way his strike was going
if you pay attention it's going to do
his strike his strike is going this way
I'm just going to extend
it so I'm not going to let it go go and
I didn't affect it didn't affect his
balance his energy is going and I'm
going to go here and extend it this
way home it's already starting starting
over
here home this one go a little
slower well this has to go this way
can't go like this this it takes his
body takes his body takes his body this
way now I'm going to step into this part
here his body's going that way I'm going
to step into
it so same drill we already made those
notes but he goes war I'm going to yield
war and I step into
it
Pop I want you to pay attention to this
tip don't don't chase eeko
yet
okay let's
try so uh you kind you kind par this
just to the side you see but his elbow
stays on the bottom cuz on yokomen it is
on the
bottom okay you see and I need his elbow
to go to go over I need his elbow to go
over harder hope you see need his elbow
to go over the top you see
that so you can't go here and then you
don't change his
elbow this this maneuver here boom is CH
his elbow over do you see and then
that's where you will find the elbow so
you'll
Parry here boom happens there here it is
the pass then you have have to enter
before you get
there goes boom turn it over
boom do it
again again
sorry go go go
again make sure you got you can put some
p in there again you go here we
go
again
turn your face the other
way okay let's try Okay uh depending on
your level just work on that and this is
going to get a little
bit
more difficult so we'll divide you rank
order okay uh let's look
at okay so if I was going to do eil
let's let's do it for
real okay so I'm going to move out and
do the inward
spiral on the inward
spiral is what takes his
balance my base is not
homolateral it's cross lateral
which means right hand left
knee so he is going to step through for
Yen stop put that leg in the back okay
but he can't start a million miles away
he's close okay and I move in boom go
throw it
home and we'll just work on that kazushi
part okay so I
[Music]
reach
boom I want to hit his
body don't worry about the second hand
for now you're too far
away
boom keep keep throwing don't worry
about me I'll find
you don't worry about the second
[Music]
half
okay let's try that and I'll try to work
the second arm so so he's
going try to work that second
arm and the
step second
arm
it and the
[Music]
step okay nice
try
so what I'm what I'm going to start
doing is is uh getting the arm out of
the way and getting the hip I don't want
to worry about the the arm so he's going
P I want my hip in there you see how
that I'm not going here pull get his arm
and then he go I'm going to load my
hip he go boom there's my
hip
just
likei shui the
hip now for
yoan Bo boom hip right
there
and the arm is after the fact going have
right
now disload your
hi
okay all right so we go I follow oh I
load the hip find the
technique get be out of the arm I'd
rather you work on the hip
part you don't want your grapp to be Li
dependent
so I am touching his
elbows and my hands are lowering towards
the
floor but I'm not pushing his elbow now
his elbow is lowering towards the floor
from the kazushi and I'm staying up with
it okay so as as he goes and I go I'm
loading his
hip and so uh loading my hip so to load
my hip to load my hip I can't be pushing
him away from me he has to go around me
he has to go around me this
way he energy is going that way anyways
believe me it's going to go that way
right now it's so slow and static that
he can balance and do all that crazy
crap okay you should try to find my feet
as you can okay so he's going and you
want to feel my feet feel my feet okay
and then you feel my feet too so you
you're not balancing here you're you
have three legs on the ground do you
understand okay so as as this arm comes
around his I want his energy to go that
way
dude find my feet there you go got my
feet so as I move this arm goes this
way that doesn't change when we do this
time Bo this
way and my hips in there boom boom my
hips in there and I just stay up with
this
hand again
hips in there staying up with his
hand meaning he's already
[Music]
falling so I'm just staying up with
him
[Music]
for